un cocon végétal c'est le surnom donné
au Piton mononttvert cette forêt
semi-sèche dans les haut de Saint-Pier
abrite une flore très riche et
diversifiée 65 % des espèces présentes
sur le site sont endémiques c'està-dire
qu'on ne les retrouve qu'à la Réunion et
nul part ailleurs sur les 65 po
d'endmiss on va on va trouver
on va dire 10 espèces protégées par
arrêté ministériel donc là j'ai éocladè
monophilat
dedans on va trouver des grands nates on
va trouver des petits nates on va
trouver du bois d'olive blanc on va
trouver du bois d'olive noir qui
lui-même est caractéristique de la forêt
semi-sèche et une espèce
particulièrement rare c'est cette
orchidée caméléon caméléon parce que
cette plante ne dispose que d'une seule
feuille qui se confond dans son
environnement unique à la Réunion elle
est ainsi protégée par un arrêté
ministériel particularité de cette
orchidée ben c'est
c'est la la seule et unique orchidée du
python Montvert et endémique surtout ça
veut dire que on va pas la
retrouver sur d'autres d'autres sites à
la Réunion là elle a cette couleur là
donc elle est un peu marron tacheté on
pourrait penser que ce sont des feuilles
sèches
et si on regarde de plus près en
revanche dessous les feuilles sont sont
plus vertes pendant les weekends nature
c'est le gestionnaire du site qui fait
découvrir cet espace naturel sensible
aux visiteurs une balade riche en
anecdote la petite anecdote sur le le
bois de joli
cœur c'est que bon paraîil dans dans le
passé les gens lorsqu'il n'y avait pas
Chanel il y avait pas les grands parfums
on va dire du moins pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas les moyen d'acheter ben il
prenaent un bouquet de feuilles et et il
frottait sur eux et cetera avant d'aller
au bal
donc à partir de là une fois qu'ils
avaient fait ça ils sentaient ils
avaient une bonne odeur et depuis les
gens appellent ça joli cur le classement
de cette forêt en espace naturel
sensible permet de préserver toute la
biodiversité de ce milieu présent sur le
site les gestionnaire travaille aussi à
la sensibilisation auprès du grand
public et à la lutte contre les espèces
envah
là ce que je fais
c'est je cueille les quand c'est
possible he je je cueille les les fleurs
de ambrosade quand les fleurs sont
transformées en fruits si les fruits
sont verts ben on les casse aussi on
fait ça pour le goyavier on fait ça pour
le
galabè et puis bien surtout le les
emrosade ce sont des des des espèces
exotiques qui bien souvent dans le cadre
du ambrosade par exemple B il peut
monter jusqu'à très haut et on peut pas
grimper sur ces arbres pour couper les
les les bouquets de feuilles ou bouquets
de fleurs pardon et du coup tant dès que
c'est possible on on cueille les fleurs
et les
fruits